venezuela acumula ya 3 reconversiones
monetarias en poco más de una década es
el tema destacado para iniciar economía
de france 24 está conmigo en el estudio
daniel hablando con daniela bienvenida
venezuela otra vez cambiando su cono
monetario claro que si santiago el
primero recordemos que es una
reconversión monetaria es un cambio que
se hace en el sistema monetario
justamente para simplificar
transacciones cuando la inflación es
demasiado alta como ocurre efectivamente
en venezuela en donde el billete de
mayor denominación es que es el de un
millón de bolívares apenas cuesta 25
centavos de dólar como los sistemas de
pagos ya no pueden soportar cifras tan
altas pues el gobierno decidió hacer la
tercera operación de este tipo en lo que
va del siglo
quitando 14 ceros en apenas 13 años
ahora veamos santiago en 2008 comenzó a
circular el bolívar fuerte y ahí se
quitaron 3 ceros
diez años después surgió el bolívar
soberano y se quitaron otros cinco ceros
con la nueva reconversión que rige a
partir del primero de octubre la moneda
local se llamará bolívar digital y
tendrá seis ceros menos de esta manera
un millón
lugares soberanos serán lo mismo que un
bolívar digital y con una economía de
facto prácticamente dolarizada danielle
hablemos ahora de méxico que agregó 3.8
millones de nuevos pobres en solamente
dos años si santiago pues eso lo dice el
consejo nacional de evaluación de la
política de desarrollo social que hay 55
7 millones de pobres en este país un
número más alto que la población total
de naciones como españa colombia o
argentina esto representa un 44 por
ciento de la población y es mucho mayor
a los casi 52 millones de pobres que
había cuando andrés manuel lópez obrador
inició su gobierno a finales de 2018 el
país también agregó en dos años 2,1
millones de personas a situación de
pobreza extrema y ahora son 11 millones
y pasamos ahora a hablar de la región de
américa latina la pandemia de kobe 19
hizo retroceder la inversión en nuestra
región daniela santiago según la
comisión económica para américa latina y
el caribe la cepal la inversión
extranjera directa cayó a niveles no
vistos en la última década concretamente
en el último año debido a la pandemia el
flujo de capital foráneo en la región
fue de 105 mil millones de dólares en
2019 había sido de 162 mil millones de
dólares o sea que el descenso fue de
casi un 35 por ciento que es muy
parecido a lo que se desplomó a nivel
mundial sólo hay 5 países de la región
en los que la inversión extranjera no
cayó anoté las bahamas barbados ecuador
paraguay y méxico maneras de no sé si
esto es bueno usted nos va a aclarar
pero bajaron los precios mundiales de
los alimentos bueno pues lo hicieron por
segundo mes consecutivo en julio frente
al mes anterior aunque este es un
promedio mundial santiago no es el caso
de cada país aunque sí se mantuvieron
anales al alza los precios al menos en
un 30 por ciento si se compara con el
séptimo mes del año pasado
cuando la pandemia estaba golpeando con
mucha fuerza a varios países según la
fao que es la organización de naciones
unidas para la alimentación en julio
estuvieron más económicos los cereales
aceites vegetales y productos lácteos en
el mundo y lo que más bajó fue el maíz
el arroz está en mínimos de 2 años lo
que subió el trigo a su mayor nivel
desde 2014 el azúcar y la carne aunque
levemente bueno te tienen en la lista
para que lo tengan en cuenta hablemos
ahora de los indicadores como los cual
los principales bolsos alrededor del
mundo santiago fue un muy buen día para
la bolsa de nueva york sus índices
estándar han puesto en asa que
registraron máximos históricos en medio
de datos alentadores de empleo
las acciones europeas alcanzaron su
cuarto récord consecutivo por los buenos
reportes empresariales también animadas
por world chica y finalmente las bolsas
de américa latina la bolsa de sao paulo
cayó a pesar de que petrobras en se
disparó en más del 8% tras mostrar un
muy buen balance financiero y para el
cierre la cifra del día cuéntenos
sorpréndanos con estos valores
tengo una pregunta si a usted le regalan
una botella de whisky de cinco mil
ochocientos dólares usted que hace la
vende o se la toma la vendo y me compro
otra más barata pues mira el
departamento de estado de eeuu busca
desesperadamente una botella de whisky
de ese valor regalado por el ejecutivo
de japón al ex titular de esa cartera
mike pompeo en 2019 en un aviso público
la cartera de exteriores señaló que el
paradero de la botella es desconocido y
que hay una investigación en marcha en
eeuu los funcionarios tienen dos
opciones en estos casos entregarlos a la
oficina de archivos o comprarlos para su
uso personal pues daniela buscarla
porque pronto lo podemos encontrar
gracias a ustedes por la sintonía aquí
en france24 siga con nuestra
programación gracias